Rudy Giuliani says the special
prosecutors team is trying to frame the
president Giuliani made the comment
about Robert Muller during an interview
in Israel a group of 13 highly partisan
Democrats that make up the Muller team
excluding him are trying very very hard
to frame him to get him in trouble when
he hasn't done anything wrong
Giuliani also says the Muller team
cannot come to grips with the fact that
collusion did not happen members of the
US House can go ahead with their summer
vacation plans the House Majority Leader
says the August recess is still on even
as senators plan to work through most of
it exactly what those senators will be
working on well that's still undecided
here's chief congressional correspondent
Mike Emanuel the Majority Leader Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell may have
bought himself more time to check some
items off his list of priorities we need
to confirm more of the president's aim
and judicial nominees we need to take up
regular appropriation bills we need to
tackle legislative priorities like the
water infrastructure bill the farm bill
the defense bill and many others so the
Senate will remain in session in August
but at least one GOP senator has a
priority of his own keeping president
Trump's trade policies in check because
they're utilizing it in this
unprecedented way what we've asked is
how you can continue to do all the
things you're doing and negotiate but
once you complete the work you have to
submit it to us for approval because
tariffs and revenues are the
responsibilities of Congress not the
executive branch and the Democratic
leader tipped his hand on how he wants
to spend autist now that the Senate is
in session this link to his base why
don't we get something done on the issue
that numerous polls say is the number
one priority of Americans health care we
Democrats are entire caucus believes
this previously unscheduled session time
can be put to good use
president Trump applauded McConnell's
call to keep the Senate working saying
on Twitter great maybe the Democrats
will finally get something done other
than their acceptance of high crime and
high taxes his praise may have fallen on
deaf ears with House Majority Leader
McCarthy who said he has no plans to
keep the house open telling reporters I
understand why the Senate needs to
finish their work we've been doing our
work and the man whose job McCarthy is
eyeing wants to thread the needle on an
issue that threatens to derail the GOP I
feel good about the kind of
conversations we're having our members
are earnest and sincere in trying to
understand each other's perspectives we
have a big big big swath of views within
our conference on this issue and I
really do believe that there's a sweet
spot here to be clear McCarthy is not
attacking McConnell he's merely noting
the house has passed hundreds more bills
and he too blames Senate Democrats for
obstruction but with some of the items
on the to-do list controversial he might
just turn out to be a long hot summer in
Congress Chanin all right Mike Emanuel
on Capitol Hill thank you Mike